and it will be for a half an
hour inshallah. As usual with
our classes, we don't to
make them very long. This isn't
really a class in the sense
that you need to have a pen and
paper here. However, if you
want to really learn, if you
want to really retain what it
is you hear here, it's most for
you to follow along with us in
the Quran as many people do not
memorize, don't know aren't
very familiar with it. Why was
this chapter chosen? Even
though many of us aren't
familiar with this chapter so
much. Reason I chose this
chapter is because this chapter
captures a theme which is often
overlooked in the Quran. And
that is the kinship that is
found amongst the prophets and
messengers. A spiritual kinship
What does that mean? All of the
prophets and messengers have
the same, the same religion,
all of them. All of them have
the same religion. All of them
are Muslim in the linguist
linguistic sense. in the
linguistic sense
They are all Muslim. And they
all have the same calling. And
they all have the same
vocation. And they all say the
same things. And they all have
the same core values and
beliefs. And they all have the
same struggles with their
people. And with their enemies.
So just as the prophets and
messengers all called to the
same thing. Likewise their
enemies always throughout have
tried to respond to them and
tried to refute them and
discount their prophethood with
the same old arguments. Nothing
new has come upon the thought
of humanity with regards to
rejection of the prophets and
messengers. The way they say it
may be a little different. It's
maybe a little fancier. In our
time, it's the same thing.
Nothing has changed. The way
that people try to reject
prophethood, the way they try
to reject specifically the
prophet Muhammad because people
are of different different
types. There are some that
reject all prophethood. There
are some that reject even the
existence of a creator. Some
that say there is a creator but
there's no prophethood and
there's no organized religion
as they say. Some will reject
some prophethood but except
other parts of prophethood. So,
they'll accept some prophets
and not others. Some will
accept prophethood and accept
the prophet Muhammad but not
accept everything that he came
with. So, they were portions of
that such as him being the last
messenger and prophet. They
will reject that. So, they
claim that there are still
prophets amongst us and people
that are still going to be
prophets after him, etcetera.
So, the types of people are
different and their disbelief
is the same. They come from
different places. They come
from different languages and
different cultures but their
argument is more or less the
same. It revolves around the
same tricks that a Shaitan has
been playing on humanity since
the inception. And so this
chapter captures that and
discusses that. One of the most
important things that this
chapter discusses is the
commonalities amongst the
prophets and messengers which
we are going to discuss in
add some link. The prophet
Muhammad said
we the prophets, we are
paternal brothers.
And then he explained what that
meant and said, our mothers
vary, yet our religion is one.
So, when the prophet says here,
our religion is one. We under
that this is an analogy of
their spirits and their their
call. It is not that they are
literally blood relatives, all
of them in that sense. Rather,
what is meant is we all have
different mothers, yet our
religion is one. So, the
religion of Islam, worship of
Allah alone without any
partners, the worship of Allah
alone, in the way that he has
instructed only. That is the
call of every single prophet
and messenger to have ever
graced this Earth. However,
their mothers vary. What does
that mean? Their mothers vary,
meaning that
details of some of their laws,
some of the prohibitions and
obligations that were placed
upon them, that they were
prohibited from, may vary and
that is based on Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's
discretion and wisdom of what
is most efficient for that
people and that place and that
time. It's very important that
we understand something. All of
the prophets have the same
religion the core religion of
Islam and Islam. The second
thing is that all of the
prophets and messengers have
the same core values. Not only
just the same religion but the
same core values. What are the
core values? The core values
are the five pillars of Islam.
All of the prophets and
messengers came with those five
pillars of Islam. The core
values that Lying was never
okay. Murder was never okay,
right? consuming filth,
intoxicants, fornication, these
things. This was never
prohibited. This was never
permissible in any of the
religion of any of the prophets
and messengers. Now, the
repercussions of those things
may differ. The laws may
differ. How these things are
enforced may differ. What a
consequences are may differ.
However, these core values
never changed. They were always
similar. They were always the
same Al Ambia, Jamru, Navi,
[Silence]
in when we when we recite be.
Oh prophet, yes, it's core
meaning is profit but its
linguistic meaning is One who
is profound in stature.
Somebody who is highly
esteemed. Someone who is worthy
of much respect. and it is also
recited and then in the Arabic
language is one who brings to
us immense news Some kind of
thing about the past or the
future or the present that is
immense in its nature. This is
what a Nebah is. As Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
and
so this chapter here is 112
verses we're going to discuss
probably three or four verses
each day inshallah until we
finish the chapter with the end
of Ramadan
of gatherings. Yes, we may not
have memorized the chapter.
Yes, we may not memorize
everything that I have to say
and I don't expect anyone
listening to. However, the mere
action of participation in
these kinds of and these kinds
of gatherings is what paves the
path for each of us to
paradise. The prophet said,
Allah,
[Silence]
Allah, the Masjid, reciting the
Quran, and deliberating and
discussing and meditating over
its meanings except that the
tranquility will descend upon
them. The angels will surround
them mercy will envelop them
and Allah will mention them and
make mention of them with those
who are closest to him.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. So, the
point here is not to just You
need to come. If you come, you
need to memorize everything.
You need to learn every single
thing that's said. If you try
to do that, you're probably
going to set yourself up for
failure and so after five or 10
days, you start to slow down
the novelty of Ramadan starts
to kind of go away. P, it
starts to dissipate. People
kind of start to revert back to
their old ways. You know,
Ramadan's not so special after
the first week or so and you
know the numbers start to
decrease and people start to,
I'm not saying that that's what
needs to happen. I'm saying
that that often happens and
when it does, we need to not
let that dictate our actions,
right? And we also need to not
let these kinds of things.
Dictate whether we will
continue to attend these kinds
of classes or not. Just because
you didn't learn much or just
because you think you didn't
learn much or you didn't
memorize everything that was
said or if I gave you some kind
of you know, fantastic a quiz
you wouldn't be able to solve
it doesn't mean that you
haven't learned anything and
you haven't benefited anything.
You've benefited quite a lot.
And Amir exhibition of patience
in this kind of sitting,
articulates a lot about one's
character. So, we ask Allah
Subhanahu wa ta'ala to bless us
in these gatherings and to
enlighten our hearts and to
guide us as we read through and
meditate and contemplate the
verses of the book of Allah
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. Subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
the original reference must
have from which all other are
drawn. The first half was
written by Abu Bakr
meaning
by his order. It was
collected by Zaid and it was
documented all in one book and
in the order in which the
prophet recited the Quran to
Jibreel the last time of his
life. This is called the the
last review, the last revision.
What is that? Well, you know,
the Quran was revealed here
there versus sometimes chapters
collectively, sometimes parts
of chapters, sometimes
introductions to chapters,
sometimes endings to chapters,
etcetera. So, the Quran was
revealed in spats and
these chapters would be
collected and documented by the
companions, by the prophet
scribes and he would instruct
them where to place, what
verse, and what chapter, and
where. Now, every year during
the month of Ramadan,
The prophet would recite the
Quran to Jibreel.
so he would recite the Quran to
Jibreel. And if there were any
new verses, it would be
categorized. These verses would
be placed in their proper
order, etcetera. At the last
year of his life, the tenth
year after, well, the ninth
year after Hijalah, the prophet
met Jibreel during the last
Ramadan, Ramadan of the ninth
year after Hijra, and
he revisited the Quran with
Jibreel twice this last year.
The last year of his life. This
incident is referred to by the
scholars as the last revision,
the last review And that is
that the prophet recited the
entirety of the Quran to
Jibreel Alaihi Salam. And he
recited it to him in the order
that it is found in the Mushaf
today. So we know for
that the first chapter to be
revealed was right? So, that's
not the first chapter in the
order of the Mushaf. The first
chapter in the order of the is
etcetera and the last of these
chapters is
that. So, the the book that we
have
with Surat and Nes in the order
that it is
viewed the Quran with Jibreel
and recited it to him in this
order. In this order. And
there's many reasons why we
come to that conclusion, which
we don't have time to get into.
The point is, is that this
first Mushaf was collected by
after many of the companions
were murdered in various wars
in Harubarida during the time
of Abu Bakr Sadiq. It was an
idea that Omar Abdul Khabab had
first conceived and
be even before him
The
point is, is that the
companions collectively decided
to document the most half into
one, one book, one must have.
After this, we go through the
and this book, this most half
remained in the remained in the
custody of Abu Bakr. When Abu
Bakr passed away, he passed on
this must have
and Omar kept this Mushaf with
him throughout his Khalifa.
When he passed away, he passed
this Mushaf and his custody
onto his daughter and the
prophet wife, Hafsa. And so,
this must have remained with
Hafsa. Of course, it wasn't a
small little neat we have
today, right? The writing was
very big and it's a huge book.
It's not something you're
going to misplace, right? It's
not something that be easily
confused with other books. The
companions deterred people and
highly discouraged people from
writing the Quran in small
print. This was prohibited in
the times of the of the
companions. And who was known
to physically reprimand people
during his for writing the most
in a small print. Out of their
respect for the most huffing
out of their respect for the
words of Allah. So, the Mushaf
was mandatory written in a very
large print. After Omar Ali
Allah who passed away was
murdered.
was the Khalifa of the Muslim
in and much discrepancy had
occurred throughout the Muslim
world with regards to the
recitation of the Quran. You
there's different recitations,
different companions had gone
to different places and resided
there and people would come and
learn from them and then when
they would meet for Hajj,
specifically for Hajj or Jihad
or whatever from these
different places, different
people are reciting the Quran
in different ways and it was
causing conflict and so,
again, commissioned and three
young men from Quraish to write
the to basically to to scribe
these this that was with Hafsa
to make about five or six or
seven copies. It's a difference
of opinion amongst this
historians. How many copies
there were? And for one of
these copies to be sent to
every major, every major
capital of the Muslim Empire.
So, one was sent to Iraq, one
was sent to Bahrain and one
opinion, one was sent to Asham,
one was sent to Yemen, one
stayed in Madina, one was sent
to and it's a difference of
opinion how many of these if
there were but the point is
that is referred to as
this is referred to as the
Earth Manny in reference to
Earth Manny bin Athen it is
referred to as Arthmani script
or many, book, or copy. That
book, every other that is
printed till today has to be
taken from that book. It has to
be in accordance with that
book. It can't differ with it.
If it differs with it, it has
to be thrown out. Now, that
book isn't just written. I
mean, it's memorized by
millions and millions of
Muslims and scholars all
throughout the Muslim world
throughout the ages but the
point is, is that, that is the
essence of where we have the
most have today. Now, when we
examine those books, we find
something interesting with
regards to this is referred to
as the we find in that original
Mushaf of Earthman there were
no numbers, there were no
numbers for the pages, there
were no dots, you know, like
the has one. and has one dot
underneath. There were no dots.
There were no valves written
the and all that stuff.
There were none of these
things. So, the the the book
was very bare. It was just the
shape of the letters and that
was enough to know at that
time. Those things hadn't been
invented yet. These were
actually introduced later. The
dots, dotting system was
introduced in the time of
also things the number of
portions of the Quran, the also
the
these half of a which is 10
pages, certain amount of
verses. These things were
introduced in the time of and
so, that original must have is
what the rest of all the were
taken from and that's what our
today is taken from. Actually,
if you open up your to the end
to the back page, you'll find
that it mentions the chain of
narration of that particular
Moshaf and all of them go back
to Abdullah bin Masood and
Arthman Abin Afan and Ali Abin
Abhi Talib and so and so these
they all go back to that
original whatever we find in
that is all considered to be a
Quran. Everything that was
written in that original
manuscript is considered to be
the words of Allah purely.
Without anything else. So,
there were no numbers, there
were no number of verses, there
were no pages, and this is one
thing I want to mention here
very quickly and that is. this
kind of obsession that has come
up lately and it's kind of
started back in the seventies.
We don't have to get into the
story behind it but it's been a
real big thing where people
will come and they'll do this
kind of numerological thing
with the most half and it's
this verse at this number,
and this number of verses means
this and this number of verses
and if we add that to this,
then we have this over here and
by the time you're done, you're
wearing a tinfoil hat and you
are talking all kinds of
silliness This has nothing to
do with the actual Mushaf.
These numbers that we find on
the verses, they are not the
numbers of. They are not
necessarily absolutely agreed
upon amongst the scholars.
There are different schools of
thought with regards to how to
count the verses of the Quran.
Hadith
was
Yani, Yati,
[Silence]
this many verses in this
chapter and this chapter's
title is this and that means it
means this and we derive
meanings through this
methodology. This is something
which is not permissible
amongst the scholars of Islam.
The serious scholarship of
Islam does not allow these
types of things. The numbers of
the verses in the Quran is a
difference of opinion. Some of
the verses that the companions
themselves even differed is
this two verses or one. They
don't differ on what the verse
says. They don't differ on the
number of letters or the number
of words. They differ on. If
this is an independent verse or
if it's an individual verse.
So, these kinds of things that
are kind of brought out and
before with Rashid Khalifa and
and you know, the number
nineteen and all these things.
This is something which is
rejected by the scholarship of
Islam. This is not something
that is permissible. The
meanings of the Quran are
preserved just as the Quran is.
It's preserved by the lineage
of scholarship that we have
with us. and so, it's important
that we not kind of follow all
of these new things that come
out and people come up and they
say that you know, the the
miracle of the Quran's
numerology and all of these
things. This is not something
which is considered a science
in or any kind of serious
discipline in the science
Tafseer and the signs of
understanding the Quran. It's
important for us not to get
sucked into these kinds of
things and what's worse yet is
some of these folks will come
up with fantastical events that
are going to occur, you know?
some say, you know, 911 was
in the Quran and some say, you
know, the end of this place is
going to happen at this time or
it's this year is going to be
the you know, the end of the
world or any of these things
and of these things have been
said. This is not to be
ascribed to the Quran. This is
not stated in the Quran and
much of this revolves around
conjecture and presupposition
and revolves around a lot of
shady characters. some of
them have claimed to be
prophets. Some of them have
claimed to be messengers and so
on and so forth. So Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala